yeah he went welcome to this video cream
bar Zuko 712 432 a them just a couple of
games ago in a dragon let's see what he
has in store here right before the is a
good move here it looks a little bit
cool but it's perfectly fine for black
so please dream we try something there
Gavin tonight uhit's just incredibly
stupid piece how do you play that with
water maybe still clean be through to
prevent anything coming to before after
the Queen trade well anything cannot
prevent it it's a most things now maybe
c5 is an option takes takes and I'm
ready for before not that it looks
particularly great but maybe I should
still do it this is probably equal that
line is really not not so great for wide
that night is especially five night
before hmm so what to do before before
maybe maybe before b5 is something that
I can manage like be four nights c7 I
have Bishop f4 so if he goes there I
have two shouldn't fall
after 95 and might I might have a little
something with ideas like c6 at the
right moment I mean nothing special so
much it might be possible let's get this
here the other thing that could be
interesting if getting the night over
285 I wonder about 9 h 5 yeah I think I
think I am this one okay I believe I
need a night in this position so the
only thing that looks kind of
interesting here so he's ready to take
this home okay understandable I wonder
at bishops in seven is good she actually
he might I know he might want to avoid
that I still would take and interesting
she trying to move with this around okay
I after it's one of those cases where
you have to bite the bullet if you get
to Knight to c6 I have absolutely zero
hope for anything at all
see I'm threatening to take and play
with these five simple of it okay I'll
get the nice porn porn ash in the center
ready 45 in head looks dangerous for
black the other thing that is possible
is some e 5 and try the night to go to
e4 2d6 it's also tough to fire think t5
is going to be the way to go just got
Bishop to f6 the tech might be to pawn I
can come up with loopy tool yeah this
would actually encourage e5 but I don't
want to
a good player prevented d phi for the
time being still cannot play d 5 SB 2
are saying at the end a d5 ed ed rupee
to clean youtube you should be too it's
still not fun for like so what what to
do I one day and night we can prepare it
like that
yes but it felt this is a little
improvement at least for me as probably
has to go back to f6 I'm threatening
defied again now
now I could try to get this night to the
six business in the mix yeah I wonder if
this is good experto if it is good the
night on d6 Idzik is deeply annoying
with okay there's something wrong with
that and maybe be six now no no that's
not a problem okay and I think it's not
a problem also because of of this now i
can switch now to look a to stuff as a
six now is reached let's go in
hmm defending this pretty well in night
a 70 Scott Lucas e5 I hated those
miracle move ahead sometimes just work
and okay look a six is plays Bishop c5
amazing so don't they don't tell me I
have to take on p6 I could be sick this
is this I can actually do that yeah I
can do that okay I am threatening a
drink c6 enced antiques and boldest I
think too much so C 667 no doesn't work
amazing um c 6 I know it s look at
winning appeals come on it works I have
nine to five and I'm winnings winning
the bishop because of who Kade so 918 96
yeah yep Luke takes again you KH and if
you takes pawn takes you cannot take
artistic swiss-made so this should be
the end of it
right it's made check check leak Oh
tough game yeah what well played yeah
thnkx things I actually think it was
well played i was i have to say unless
than the end it improves me otherwise
i'm pretty happy that I then I got
something out of this position which
didn't really promise all that much like
here it didn't didn't feel particularly
great to me I think he's ok but somehow
it I got something something they are 94
our problem just curious i think here
here i really have to know something
like five given by the comp may be 46
immediately oh and then at 3g for him
[Music]
and this is a better version of the game
in some way and it's a bit awkward gym I
have to take now yeah if he gets in 96
now this is nice i think it's just just
a one-sided position where black is
somewhat suffering a bit surprised that
the engine is not giving me more here ok
now it gets the evaluation gets higher
because encoder really felt like I'm
basically winning now and I'm not
screwing it up the combined ideas of d5
and 85 putting in 96 look pretty awful
and now I think it was a good decision
yeah probably I probably can play better
hear this he had really played that well
yeah that's counter play he was a five
can you funky three but what about my
more is that we looking ok so nice and
it seems to work out yes why I
calculated this correctly yeah yes this
problem if I if he goes here I take on
these six and if it takes here I'll do
that as well i was thinking c6 maybe one
looks these three of course but taking
us better he doesn't have this
opportunity 926 given by the comms ok
huh but this is good right I mean I
think I'm doing okay in and she cannot
just cannot save this check check later
it was probably disappear played ok guys
thanks for watching